そうですはいえー
あやさ者下地肇社長ですあの子ですねちょっと言わせていただくと
好き嫌いかマジで大杉本当に多分皆さんの相当の5倍くらいて好き嫌いしてるから本当
の音普通の人間からしたらそんなに嫌いなものあるのぐらい綺麗なものが多くて唯一
好きなのが
カルピスらしいです甘いんじゃねーぞあ
甘いんじゃねぇ頭一つとか2つならわかるけどあいつもう何か言うとペリーとあるいは
いいですあれはいいですもう嫌だ方で多すぎるんですよ
彼のつけすぎ嫌いとか嫌いなものが多しついてですね
こんな僕が責任を持ってるんです切っちゃう少しでも治せるようにちょっと頑張って
みようと思いますすぐに
聞こえてないんだ今外へと結構今部屋が荒れてるんですよすぎてやばいてエンチャリっ
子日本も釣るんですけどね
色々とつながってるんですけどもいろいろ食べ物飲み物買い厚め散らばっているんです
けども録画できる限りであらゆる食べ物飲み物にデスソースを入れていこうと思います
相手好き嫌いが多いんで逆に言えば好きなものも多いんですよ
好きなものと切られたものだ
はっきり分かれてるんで好きなものばっかり食べてちゃダメたよっていうのをせるため
に彼の好きなものをほとんどに部屋にあるも全部捏造鯖瀬てもう何食っても何飲んで何
をしてもです造成が入ってるっていう最高の苦しみを味あわせてやろうと思います
壁掛けのチーズバーガーつ
ます
色があった
[音楽]
なった
はぁ
[音楽]
ん
too
ああああああ
[音楽]
ん
えっん
ます
[音楽]
うぉ
それにへ
はいっえっ
いいなさいいですよ家頭を振って去っ
ここに入っ
a
あと食べれるやつあります何ずいぶんれた曲と一つでパクトン
クエスト9分技術を捻るようだ嫌いだめだって本当に
です大嫌いの牌鬼屋さんは軽いけどさん
うんうん
ん
バーザ2分アウト
いやーそんなもんだと思うブルー
た親じゃなかってないと言ってねこれが変わるか言ったじゃないですか
イヤホンでもそんなもんそうだっけやぐや演歌4 o 4
でも
はっはーブックカフェ香庵山寝るだけなんですね
ゾクッ
r 4
[音楽]
いや払い者やこれをパンではどんな感
探しば何でもいいから流れが高さは入ってますねほんとになんでもええ感じでそうじゃ
ない
ドルもあるか俺再生
んだぞ麻生者なんだよ
です何でじゃあなーまあねはカネくん
ああああああ
wl ウォンはた常にバック園はすぐ
株価レナおばあちゃんだけどめっっ
はあああああ
だ俺生空っぽ塗ってあるんだねぇ
[拍手]
ブーバーある
であ5号では市堀自分でめっちゃ件数僕いつまで嫌いなのは自己愛型です
場合は柔らかなんですけどよろしくねーな
[音楽]
を奪った
ああどうすれどスレ立っホラーコナーこれが嫌いなの
それだけがお前松山伊予
くんねえねえねほんとはロボットに持って行って山田と言われなければレモンに嫌いな
のでに思ってるくらいの秒いけアンた
ばーさーああわあ
の水道しかないよあっへへんっはい
ログ的なんじゃそれにクリームなら大丈夫ロリ系ニスキックオフが
ワーク系粕毛讃岐んですかねパコンっ
うわあああああ dero
わっ
だった
aname
car
teame
うううう
me
杉中わけじゃないですか